[Music]
Steve you're always talking about how
our privacy is something I hate it if
dick I hate it be concerned with our
privacy is being [ __ ] with you know
that it seriously pose no solution oh
well I mean I was wondering where yeah
wait whatever no we are privacy's
[ __ ] with constantly sittin because
we give it away and we openly give it
away all the time that's true I want to
be like protected but then if Apple
makes me sound like a new like updated
thing our story yeah or even bit because
the people we vote for all the time no
matter which party they all go for the
[ __ ] spy bill and I will get mad
about it yeah and on facial recognition
tell my face too
I know you also my face yeah I don't
think at all so you know my worst
nightmare is getting arrested for
something or not getting arrested by
having my mug shot like all over or but
my picture but it's not like it's not a
mug shot it's just like a really bad
angle of me from the iPhone because all
they could get yeah oh my god that's
like my worst nightmare well yeah so
this guy named Zachary he he was viewed
as a prime suspect for a burglarized
home because of the fact that he was
just doing his typical bike ride past
this home around the same time that the
burglar is burglarizing was happening
and the reason why a lot of burglars
newsbytes by the way that's a hot tip
yeah seriously
I'm going with it anyway so then the
reason why they called Zachary in is
because he had an app that was tracking
his run or like his bike rides with run
something run runner oh thank [ __ ] for
that run keeper and okay but because of
that that's when the police they're able
to work with Google or like send in a
warrant to Google and pretty much cast
this really wide net called
a geofence warrant and that's when the
police are requesting certain data from
Google and whoever uses Google's
services will be in this data if it just
so happens to like fall
certain curious and so that's exactly
Destin's that gray stuff popped up and
he was like what the [ __ ] any man
burglarized his home I was just riding
my bike post because of the fact that he
rode it a couple of times like rode past
it a couple times he was viewed as a
prime suspect and luckily nothing
happened to him because he was able to
get a lawyer really early on in the case
before Google gave the cops any actual
information about him it was just the
device and Google has this policy that
sends a notice to whoever is getting
looked into so that's how he was able to
hop on it really quickly but so he had a
Google device not an apple juice apple I
know it says no to the government all
the time which I love well probably
because they want more money for it
that's what that's what the [ __ ] I would
do I'd be like you want this data fine
bill 50 billion billion billion the
whole government deficit give it to me
[ __ ] pray to say the deficit that you
get afford to pay yeah so the thing is
that he was using and this exercise
tracking app RunKeeper to record his
rights right I said that but then the
app the app relies on his phone's
location services which he uses through
Google oh yeah so yeah it's pretty scary
times because now he's saying like yeah
these service yeah I don't see Hill
Climb at the window yeah not so much
yeah so you're telling me my man got an
email from Google that said you were
being looked into by the FBI
and he immediately got a lawyer I would
have thought it was spam saying same
well it was it's cuz there was like a
some sort of like number a case number
kind of thing where he was able to look
into it and then furthermore he found
out that it has something to do with
burglarized home and yeah he just he ran
the steps and he was able to get out of
it luckily but I guess this article's
out just to kind of say like hey you
know maybe there should be some more
precautions around this because a lot of
innocent people are getting caught in
this giant leap like giant castle wide
net what if it was all decentralized
right what if there wasn't one entity
that could pull your information and
instead of that you could go on your jog
or your [ __ ] run or whatever and and
the app is still sending you data but
there's no one place to to audit or to
go to to say like hey we're seizing your
records you have to give it to us or
what if like that's what the [ __ ] crypto
is about maybe for him he could have
like gotten a notification it's like hey
there's a burglary did you do it and you
can just hit yes or no that's true but
we have to decentralize the Internet
that's what I think
how how exactly do we do that well it's
already done right so a lot of in a lot
of cases like for example Bitcoin the
way the Bitcoin works right it's all
decentralized so you don't have to ask
an entity if it's ok for you to make a
transaction with two people you can just
do it yeah and there's no permission
it's a permissionless based system so if
you could do that with an app like like
a map that that tells you how many miles
you ran you don't have to go to one
entity there's there is no one entity
it's all actually backed up by many
different places at the same time so
there's no just like the internet is so
you can't like attack the internet at
one point because the internet can't be
taken on at one point because it's it's
it's hosted so many places that's the
same thing as this it would be hosted so
many places that you can't go to one
place and to say give me his data and
that's what we all need that's actual
privacy otherwise you have no [ __ ]
privacy at all which is how it is a lot
about it it's true it drives me crazy
man crazy given Android
no I would love it I prefer Google
anything yeah a PC guy I'm a PC guy
I prefer PC and I prefer Android not
Google anything but I prefer Android but
preferred does not mean I love yeah it's
just about like privacy in general and
actually Apple not cooperating with the
government on many cases I like that
about Apple but what I hate about Apple
is it - it's basically a closed system
you're obsessing your Apple watch well I
know I like all the [ __ ] in
because I'm working out and [ __ ] with it
but but what sucks about it is that
somebody could take that data and use it
against me or anything like some run huh
no I'd be like oh this guy does not like
to run or like they can check out
Steve's Mac speed on his watch and
they're like yeah he didn't do it very
strong look I don't know about quick I
don't know about very fast I want to
race you in a 5-mile race huh I want to
race you in arms
die in a one-mile race I walk that mile
in height let's do a 250 foot - that I
can do I like how they're collecting all
of this data on it like Apple could
literally clone me at this point like
they're collecting all this data but the
first thing they do with it they're like
all right how do we generate more sales
more sales sales sales market it sell it
buy it stop it ship it love it though
that's the first [ __ ] move and now
they're like okay government stuff but I
feel like there's a cost too much money
to clone so much more productive things
that you could do dude Apple has all my
pictures otherwise they'd be off of it
already that's why I don't send nudes
don't sin is also I can't get my [ __ ]
pictures like just for the cloud no I
can't like if I get a new phone you
can't get those pictures from you can
you just don't understand how I don't
understand I got a new phone I
downloaded my cloud photos but all my
videos they don't work hmm
you got a download it takes more time to
download the video why don't you decide
when I there your FBI guy oh by the way
if you delete a photo from Apple on your
phone it deletes it from the cloud so
[ __ ] you Apple [ __ ] you so much like why
why does have to be connected because
then I have to have memory for my phone
for the [ __ ] cloud yeah why hey guess
what pay $2 extra and you can upgrade
your memory so you can use your camera
again I don't upload anything to the
cloud night Russell what do you plan I
just delete it or I get a smaller phone
a tinier phone it needs to keep those
memories creating those memories are
just gonna [ __ ] you later on yeah they
are what are you gonna do cry about it
look back on the past remember the great
times better things [ __ ] that [ __ ]
to review what people do delete it
trunk full of daily journals that I've
kept since I was 15 and they have
printed pictures and them so I guess I
could delete mcleod move on like
documenting move on move on grab booking
them everything I love documenting I got
in another life you were such a cat lady
my goal is to get a big enough place
where we have one level that's just cats
ah that's for us
you're grown north wing so here's all
you've seen it you've seen it then a
stop and they start licking itself again
like that's exactly what you're doing in
the room but I'm are they doing it do
this [ __ ] while they're doing it like
this yeah the tongues I gotta get it out
that's it guys the room is not the
tavern why does my cat always need to do
that on the goddamn carpet I'm sorry
don't dog does a P every where we're
here like trading them I hate talk sue
oh okay anything that's not bringing in
money in my house yeah my daughter's dog
I don't walk him I don't feed him I
don't water him I don't do a lot water
have you told your daughter to put her
put him on Instagram uh yeah yeah have
you seen that oh it's an industry man I
don't know man another video cuz he
doesn't see anything he ever heard of no
grumpy cat before yeah you know I don't
literally don't think about this doll he
never comes out when I'm home by myself
which is part of me because I don't ever
want to interact with this dog like I
just I'm not a fan of anything that you
got to take care of for life what's the
name what's the breathe yes well she's
gonna get old enough to get the [ __ ] out
my house you can help out occasionally
but yeah you had to take care of the
daughter longer than the dog lives the
dog lives like 15 years but in theory he
has to take care of the dog a hundred
percent of the time whereas with the
daughter he only has to take care of her
for twenty seven percent of the time and
I like that and not only that like she
gets he got old enough slight learn how
to cook on set she walks to school on
her own [ __ ] she basically just
some money every now and then and a
couple of hugs this is she straight but
the dog the dog you always have to pick
his [ __ ] up yep
like he never gets old enough or he's
like I'm gonna be responsible [ __ ] that
suck and dogs you can't leave them alone
like casually leave a long for a couple
of days baby straight long food or water
they have a dog then muffles me what do
you know what this cooperative smiles
like [ __ ] this dog know what they might
know whether you think earlier I saw a
tweet that really got me thinking it
says some [ __ ] like what if cats and
dogs can really talk they just choose
not to
oh man my cat will talk so much [ __ ]
well the things he seen you guys want to
talk about freaky [ __ ] would have
exactly that voice like the worst
creepiest was a baby smoke Azula [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]